mario has been starring in games for  over 30 years but have you ever wondered  how old he actually is I'm Tony and this  is your ageless GameSpot news update so  how old is Mario a 2005 interview with  Shigeru Miyamoto recently resurfaced and  the creator said everyone's favorite  Italian plumber is only 24 or 25 years  old and insert joke about Mario being a  millennial that also means that 50  something Bob Hoskins was playing a man  in his 20s in the Super Mario Brothers  movie talk about range also since baby  mario has made more than a few game  appearances prepare for some fan-made  mario timelines the next adventure for  the mushroom kingdoms finest is Super  Mario run coming to iOS devices this  December with an Android release to  follow he's quite busy for a man barely  past his college years to keep up with  all the Super Mario news you're already  in the right place  you